i thought to myself this person would be
my friend you know and you don't find
that every day either
so uh it's a very special thing for both
of us
that was jennifer lopez talking about
her then fiance
ben affleck back in 2003 before they
called it quits in 2004
but now things are heating up between
the two again
and a source tells e.t that j-lo is
loving it i'm thrilled i am really happy
quote jen is loving the attention she
has been getting from
ben jen and ben didn't get along at the
end of their relationship
years ago but once their hurt feelings
subsided
they were friendly for many years now
that they've fully reconnected
they are having fun together and care
about each other a great deal
this is a thrill you know i can't stop
smiling
the two started dating in 2002 while
starring in their first movie together
julie
i'm sorry do we know each other not yet
they quickly got engaged but by 2003
they called off their wedding just days
before their planned september ceremony
and they officially split in january
2004.
it was my first like adult heartbreak
was it because it was so
public and we wanted to know every
single
thing about your relationship well that
didn't help
sorry we were about to get married it
didn't work out and it was just
a bad heartbreak like you know just one
of those breakups that really
you know it was like a tough one for me
for whatever reason for many reasons
jayla went on to marry mark anthony whom
she shares
13 year old twins max and emmy with but
they split in 2014 after 10 years of
marriage
and in 2019 she got engaged to former
mlb star
alex rodriguez after two years of dating
but they called off their engagement in
april now when it comes to ben fans were
surprised to see the 51 year old triple
threat move on so quickly after
splitting from
a-rod but another source told et that it
wasn't a huge surprise for jen and ben's
friends
who knew they stayed in touch over the
years
[Music]
meanwhile an additional source told et
earlier this month that the justice
league star has always
had an affinity for jennifer and says he
was the one who initially started
pursuing her
quote he wanted to explore things with
her beyond a friendship
and they've both been really enjoying
spending time together
it's great as for jlo's ex a-rod
a source told e.t that he was shocked by
how quickly she reunited with ben
she's really funny and amazing and
she's just magical she you know she
everything she touches is just
i've learned so much from her in such a
short period of time and
a second source tells et that if the
former baseball star had it his way
he'd still be with j-lo quote it was
definitely her call to end it
he would have loved for it to keep going